things are getting hot in russia's
neighborhood with the latest uprising in
kyrgyzstan
adding fuel to the fire that began weeks
ago in western neighbor belarus
where thousands had been demanding
removal of authoritarian leader
alexander lukashenko
tensions between armenia and azerbaijan
are smoldering once again
over the separatist enclave
nagorno-karabakh
russia has been delivering weapons but
otherwise showing uncharacteristic
restraint
putin's top priority long seemed to be
restoring russia's place as a global
player
has he lost his touch our title russia's
explosive frontiers what is putin's
[Music]
goal
[Music]
hello and welcome to to the point it is
a pleasure to introduce our guests
beginning with vladimir yisipov
he is a colleague here on dw's russian
desk and he says
poutine wants to keep the power and make
russia great again
and i'm very glad to have with us
alexander he's a political scientist and
analyst specializing on russia
and his view as a whole this is change
like the fall of the berlin wall in 1989
how explosive it will be remains to be
seen
and a pleasure to have with us sabina
adler she is a correspondent at german
broadcaster
and she says sowing divisions supporting
dictators subverting borders
russia remains on the wrong side of
history
so sabine adler it seems like supporting
dictators
and subverting borders used to come a
bit easier to vladimir
putin after protests over the rigged
election
in belarus began he waited weeks to
affirm his support for lukashenko
last time armenia and azerbaijan clashed
it took russia just
four days to quell the conflict
now it seems to be reluctant to stop the
fighting what's going on
i would say when it comes to
belarus this is
at the end no question for putin
who he wants to support of course
it's lukashenko and he wouldn't allow
that a mass protest can change a regime
that's what he fears all the time and
there is no way not supporting
lukashenko of course
it's possible that he creates a figure
like a so-called opposition a leader
and install him in belarus with the help
of propaganda with so-called
tv journalists and so on and fake news
and information
that's all possible but at the first
step he i i wouldn't say that
he really thought about not
confirming and not supporting lukashenko
no no idea
and vladimir you say russia wants to
hold on to
putin wants to hold on to power is his
power
actually at risk certainly his approval
ratings appear to be
declining i don't see any risks for
witness power and
to keep the power is the most normal
thing for any politician politician
political in the world so the political
systems are different but the wish
to keep manpower is the same whatever
country you take
so i don't think back to your question i
don't think any risk for putin's power
the approval ratings can go up and down
but there's no real danger for him
last time his poll ratings uh were
declining in 2012 he quickly revived his
standings with uh moves like the
annexation
of the crimea are we seeing a different
strategy now
no the ratings 2011 2012 we had a huge
mass project on the street of moscow
which were which were
de-escalated very professionally by
russian authorities
and crimea was 2014 two years later um
so i don't think any connection with the
ratings 2011
what happens to crimea three years later
sorry what was the question simply the
question of whether we're seeing a
different strategy now
when we see how russia is dealing with
uh the conflicts in the neighborhood
no the strategy on the same the focus of
the russian government is
much more geopolitical so it's what
angers the russian publics
for some reason some for some parts
because the
clearest shift from domestic issues for
economy for
medical problems which we have in
context of corona crisis
the russian government is very much busy
with gale politics with syria
libya belarus with many many issues on
the global level
and not paying much attention to the
domestic issue and it's what angers
russian public and russian russians
inside the country because i don't think
the other russian president would be
less
interested in geopolitics but probably
more interested in domestic issues
alexander
you know russia well from what i've read
you have dined
with president putin and you've also
consulted for major russian firms like
gazprom so you say in your opening
statement that the current
situation could bring about change like
the fall of the berlin whoa
what do you mean exactly where is this
change going
i mean that the world is facing
radical dramatic changes and i compare
the changes we will witness
with the changes which we have saw 30
years ago
i think that of course there is no
better involved to collapse
but the world is moving from one world
order from the i would say unipolar
world order
which was designed uh as a liberal world
order by the west by the united states
in the european union
after the end of communism we're moving
now to a new stage
in world history where the world will be
defined by major
powers not only by the west but by a
very strong china
by a by a new russia with new strengths
but
also more military-minded russia and
also a strong islamic
movement and and force which will
witness also from the south
and do you see any change in putin's
way of dealing with the tensions in the
neighborhood compared to how he might
have handled it earlier you know i just
came back from this
valdez club in moscow last week and i
asked him the question
said would he deliver again the speech
which he gave to the german bundestag
exactly 20 years ago where he said the
cold war is over
uh would you do the same speech again i
asked him
and he said yes but in a softer way and
what he confirmed is for him
is that the nato expansion was the
mother of all the problems which he
faces with the west this is a russian
view
of course but the same this is a
geopolitical fight
which the russians have today with the
west and with the russians over nato
expansion over
values or many things what i wanted to
say about the neighborhood
i think that putin is not really afraid
that the west
will take advantage of this changes in
kyrgyzstan in armenia zerbajan and
belarus hawaii because all these
countries
are much better and much closer
connected with russia than ukraine was
66 years ago
belarusia is economically completely
dependent on russia kyrgyzstan
as well because kyrgyzstan is also a
member of the eurasian club
and in azerbaijan and armenia both
countries also
get weapons from russia and are
economically
intertwined with moscow sabina very
briefly your opening statement said
russia remains on the wrong side of
history what would it take to put it on
the right
side and is vladimir putin capable of
delivering that
what alexander just said makes
me thinking about the past
the situation compared to what
we have now uh it feels like the fall of
the war
when i uh think about this former time
it was a period of happiness of hope of
of uh of joy and i can't
see this in this moment
the other way around i would say no
nothing nothing uh
what we see now is fear is
the word changes uh the corona virus
is taking uh over the lives your whole
life
and no nothing nothing at all but
to come back to the question
putin and russia on the right side of
history would mean to stop interference
in internal affairs of our other
countries sawing
uh discord in other in other countries
to to to do something with positive
energy not just
everything with such negative energy
what i
see now and that's what i mean thank you
very much
let us take a closer look at now at
where history is taking belarus
managed democracy is a term used to
describe not only russia's system but
also those of key neighbors
like belarus but many people there have
had
enough mass protests have been held for
weeks in belarus against alleged
election fraud in the presidential
election president lukashenko's security
forces have brutally beaten down the
protests
and he has thrown opposition politicians
and demonstrators in jail
but the opposition is not giving up
hundreds of thousands of belarusians
continue to take to the streets
calling for a general strike and
demanding that lukashenko stepped down
opposition leader svetlana tikranovskaya
had to leave the country for her own
safety
we are fighting for our
rights in belarus now for our dignity
and i'm sure that we will
succeed sooner or later russian
president poutine supports the
belarusian government
but is continuing to hold back as long
as lukashenko's power is not truly
endangered
amid a difficult situation in belarus
the relations with russia have a solid
foundation
how far will putin go to maintain
stability
on russia's external borders
vladimir what's your thinking in terms
of belarus could we see
regime and generational change there or
do you think lukashenko in the end will
prevail perhaps not least thanks to help
from putin
well i would divide between what we hope
to see and what we will see
i'm afraid we hope to see a regime
change or mainly in the west and many in
germany hoped
for a regime change in belarus but i'm
afraid we will not have
any regime change because the script is
like venezuela
a couple of months ago last year with mr
guido what was
declared by the best to be the president
of venezuela and
disappeared from the public view a
little time later i'm afraid
so alexander what if anything might
prompt putin to actively
intervene how close are his relations
with lukashenko
close close relations but we shouldn't
forget that lukashenko
is not a putin puppet he's doing his own
policy whenever russia is too strong for
him to press to
to to presses upon him then he runs over
to the west
in my opinion lukashenko will not
survive
the next presidency he will go but not
today in a couple of years
but before that he will change the
constitution and we will see
i think some some other powers
power momentums in this country sabine
adler if putin continues to exercise
restraint
could that incentivize opposition in
other places
kyrgyzstan for example where we're
already seeing
tensions or kazakhstan
even do you think we could see further
unrest in other parts of the
neighborhood
i would i would say that this depends on
the situation of these countries and of
course
there is no putin in the world who can
stop
people going on streets as we saw this
or see this in
belarus and in other countries not
everything
turns around putin and that's that's
very uh important to know and
not to fear just because putin
doesn't like such mass demonstrations
such colored revolutions
that they shouldn't start it and i
wouldn't agree
that this is a scenery alike venezuela
i think the time of lukashenko is over
yes he fears putin that's right
he is afraid of another annexation
in his country in this time and
this is not over but you can't stop
people thinking they want to change
as long as the change isn't done
and that's why uh i'm not so pessimistic
about belarus
vladimir you told us that uh to the
degree that there is negative public
opinion
in russia about putin it has to do with
the perception that he's not doing
enough about domestic
challenges so does it matter to
russians how he handles these tensions
and conflicts in the area
yes no yes it matters because putin
paying close attention to the probably
rating in the russian government
is concerned about the supreme rating on
one hand on the other hand there is no
such thing like
free and democratic elections in russia
so if the population is not happy with
the government there's no chance to
remove or
substitute this government with other
kind of government so
even with opposition or take navalny
he can do whatever he likes on youtube
but there's no chance for him to
be a part of establishment in order to
become a part of political establishment
and to change
the things in the country so as a
russian population you can be angry on
your government
as as much as you want but you have no
chance to change to change
things on a legal way so let me take us
to
another place in the neighborhood namely
uh the enclave of
uh nagono kara back alexander
nato member turkey is now intervening in
support of
azerbaijan while russia at least in the
past has actually delivered weapons to
both
sides so what does putin really want
there
very simple he doesn't want to lose
azerbaijan he knows that armenia is
basically part of the of russia because
it is part of the eurasian union it's
part of the military
union with russia and it's dependent on
russia but
for putin it's more
beneficial if turkey has its influence
on in the caucasus then
to have nato bases under american
supervision in the caucasus and
therefore he doesn't want to lose
azerbaijan
to nato sabine others nodding there is
turkey actually looking to challenge
russia's hegemony in the region and do
you think it could succeed
i think uh yes
yes uh it is possible but
i think the the uh in my opinion the
more important thing is that uh
erdogan turkish president is
so useful for for putin and he can't
risk to lose erwan
and erdogan is very important to sort
discord and to divide nato that's the
most important thing
and they they both
know what they do and they both won't
risk their i wouldn't say a
kind of collaboration but but they
depend on each other
and uh yeah that's why i think uh
there is a certain restrain of putin and
uh
maybe the reason uh is that vladimir the
eu has been accused of doing too little
to push back against both turkey and
azerbaijan interestingly enough russia
joined forces with france and the u.s
to call for a ceasefire is there perhaps
even an opening here in regard to
nagorno-karabakh
and the tensions between armenia and
azerbaijan for closer cooperation
between europe and russia i wish it
would be this way
i wish it so much but i'm not sure how
the thing will be developed
i absolutely agree with you putin into
erdogan
playing the game on natto it's true in
my opinion
so um i have i would not have prognosed
in any
future developments on this topic how
how close can russia
go with european union and
nagorno-karabakh
thank you very much elsewhere
cooperation between
russia and the west looks further away
than ever
following the short-lived pledge by both
sides to reset
russian-american relations an array of
developments have driven the two
further apart
ever since the successful revolution in
ukraine
the nation has been a thorn in the side
of russia's president putin
in february 2014 he annexed the
ukrainian peninsula of crimea
supported by moscow separatists in
eastern ukraine also quickly gained
ground
in syria's civil war russian troops are
fighting alongside those of the dictator
assad
after the conflict russia wants to
establish a permanent military presence
in syria
this would give russia direct access to
the mediterranean
and enable it to become a major player
in the middle east
putin also wants to exert influence in
the west using kgb methods
for example russia allegedly tried to
influence the u.s elections in 2016
using cyber attacks and spreading fake
news
american secret services suspect there
is currently a russian disinformation
campaign
designed to help trump in the current
presidential election
it shows the level of political culture
or the absence of such i reiterate we
don't interfere
will putin succeed in destabilizing the
west
alexander in many respects trump
with his undermining of trust in the
united states and its democratic system
with his
criticism of multilateralism of nato
in particular has really played into
putin's hands
would you say that is by accident or by
design yeah you will ask me probably
who is better for russia by nor putin i
think both are bad for russia
i mean for putin not for russia with uh
biden at least
putin hopes to continue uh the talks on
reality
and uh disarmament uh with
with uh trump he may create a new world
order
and this may be a dream in russia and he
knows it for trump the big enemy
is china and not russia he wants to to
make deals with russia whether biden
clearly said that russia is the biggest
threat for the west
let me come back to the question posed
at the end of that short report
uh sabine it was about whether putin is
successfully
destabilizing the west right now
authorities in both the u.s
and europe report significant evidence
of russian disinformation
campaigns putin's neighborhood may be uh
increasingly explosive as we've talked
about but is he nonetheless succeeding
quite well in exporting instability to
the united states for example
i would say yes absolutely he is an
expert
in this and we saw a very short period
of time
this where the years and years when
informational war didn't play a role
but putin revived this and
he used he uses this
as a tool as a very effective tool
to meddle in internal affairs to
uh to saw discord in
not just in uh neighbor countries like
ukraine like like black germany despite
beyond a direct neighbor but
uh and as well in the u.s and
the overall goal i think is uh
to slander democracy
itself and that's a very very uh
dangerous thing and uh it's it's more
important
than everything else i in my opinion
and uh at this point they meet together
uh trump erdogan putin and
the dictators around the world and
that's a really
new challenge and a very serious
challenge vladimir
in view of all of that and in view of
the recent attack
on alexay navalny the russian opposition
politician
should europe be doing more to sanction
putin's
abuses of power and his interference and
if so what additional measures
would work well we see
there are european sanctions in russia
since for six years from now for
the ukraine and crimea and eastern
ukraine
and the question is not if europe should
do more but how effective this
mechanism are how much how much
influence the sanctions have on the
behavior of russia
is it possible to change the russian
behavior by sanctions
and the answer is not really because we
don't have any
any substantial change in russian
behavior on the geopolitical
stage as a result of dissension
so we can discussing sanctions in europe
and europe can impose sanctions on
two more russian firms or three more
russian citizens
but the question is how how effective
these sanctions will be
alexander ross some leading german
politicians among them former chancellor
gerhard
have argued in recent years that it's
time for a german-russian
reset are those voices growing quieter
now after the attack on navalny
yeah sure they are non-existent anymore
i
think yes the problems with russia are
obvious with the europe
of the european union but at the same
time we shouldn't destroy
in my view what has been built between
germany and russia for europe for
european security in the past 30 years
and in a dramatic way that's uh this
can disappear and i think probably yes
the west
wants to punish russia then punish
russia but on the other hand there are
so
many aspects where we should cooperate
in future
because we are not in the east-west
conflict anymore but in the north-south
conflict we need
a common view on how to uh
to fight with the challenges which
stands in front of us from
the south for europe and for russia
sabine adler
ukraine crimea syria there are enormous
financial costs to putin's expansive
moves
could that prove to be a problem for him
in the end
obviously not russia is rich enough
to do this and of course it
would be much smarter to spend the money
uh in the own country but uh he doesn't
do it and i
want to say uh that i can't agree that
we as germany and russia to the same
level
destroyed the uh relationship as
alexander said that
not not germany just destroyed this
relationship not
i can't i i i have to say that
we're we're just about out of time but
let me come quickly back to our title
which asked what is
putin's goal and vladimir putin's goal
was to restore
russia's position in the world as a
global player what do you think the
history books will write will they say
he succeeded
it might succeed yes
was it short enough that was short as
can be
so a clear yes to that answer from
vladimir
espiself and many thanks to all of you
for being with us today
and thanks to all of you out there for
tuning in
see you soon bye-bye
[Music]
[Music]
you